i know many americans are asking tonight
what is america's interest here now a
troubling story from ukraine according
to the new york times a father and
husband discovered that his family died
after seeing their lifeless bodies and
photographs that were put online they
were reportedly killed by a russian
mortar attack our prayers are with that
father his entire family all the people
of ukraine the innocent men women and
children that are under fire tonight and
i think it's clear americans are asking
what is our role here let me be clear
what i think america's role should be it
needs to be no matter what happens in
ukraine
we cannot have american boots on the
ground that cannot be an option
world war iii
we we got to do our very best to try and
prevent that from happening because
that's not going to end well and frankly
there have been far too many occasions
and this is the most important point
when politicians in washington both
sides of the aisle in the u.s are eager
to start wars but then they don't have
the resolve to actually win the wars
they start then as time passes and the
wars
become less popular and become
politicized and these very same
politicians that sent our national
treasure our men and women to go fight
these wars they decide uh never mind
abort the mission oops um sorry we made
a mistake let's get out as quickly as
possible and what about the precious
loss of life in the meantime now what
happened in afghanistan and iraq can
never happen again and thank god we have
new military modern technology that can
prevent that from happening again and
don't forget its day-to-day 207 since
joe biden abandoned uh americans behind
enemy line lines in the islamic emirates
of afghanistan now many other people are
asking do we as a country have any moral
obligation to do something when we see
war criminals like vladimir putin
bombing eviscerating entire
neighborhoods you saw the the report
just now about literally attacking a
maternity ward killing women and
children indiscriminately does america
have a moral obligation my answer is yes
we do we have an obligation to help
innocent human beings especially women
and children and in this case the
ukrainian people they have now
demonstrated their willingness to fight
for their country and protect their
fellow countrymen now this is where we
can and we should help them we can help
the ukrainians by providing the arms
that they need to protect their people
that's how we help them are we choosing
sides yeah we are we're choosing the
side
of the sovereign and albeit i've been
critical of ukraine's government at
times
uh political corruption has run up until
zelinski pretty rampant
but this is a sovereign country that was
invaded and as americans we're really if
we're on anybody's side we're on the
side of innocent civilians brutally
murdered by vladimir putin and his
minions doing his bidding and that's why
it would be nice and good for the world
if the russian military or his own
advisors or the people of russia step up
and do the right thing and take that guy
out by any means necessary when you
invade a sovereign country this should
be a new rule and you kill innocent men
women and children which he has done you
forfeit your right to lead a country and
frankly you also forfeit your right to
live the world would be better and safer
without putin in it period now if we've
learned anything from the last century
where well over 100 million people human
souls died because of isms communism
nazism fascism the sooner you cut off
the head of a maniacal killer and the
cat you cut off the head of a snake
then you start saving innocent lives now
we're gonna have a lot more on putin's
bloody invasion of ukraine coming up but
first we turn to an important issue
right here at home and that is now for
the third straight day
gas prices at the pump just hit another
all-time record high joe biden says it's
all putin's fault nothing he can do
about it said those very words now joe
biden is lying we didn't get here
overnight in fact prices at the pump as
you all know have been rising ever since
joe biden took office now why have they
been rising because biden
did everything he possibly could with
the stroke of a pen to limit all oil and
gas production and exploration right
here in the u.s just like he promised
he'd do take a look
if we don't stop using
fuels
we're all dead doing away with any
subsidies for fossil fuels number one
number two holding them
liable for what they have done
particularly in those cases where your
underserved neighborhoods and you you
know the deal okay and by the way when
they don't or when they're deliberate
put them in jail kiddo
i want you to just take a look okay you
don't have to agree but i want you to
look in my eyes
i guarantee you i guarantee you we're
going to end fossil fuel and i am not
going to cooperate okay would there be
any place for fossil fuels including
coal and fracking in the biden
administration
no it would we would we would work it
out we would make sure it's eliminated
so it's going just as planned so joe
killed the keystone xl pipeline prices
went up joe banned drilling in anwar
prices went up joe block new permits on
federal lands and auctions on federal
lands and guess what prices went up joe
rejoined the paris climate accords we're
paying a fortune and china and india
viewed as developing countries and pay
next to nothing he reinstated caps on
american production he added
environmental regulations that are
almost impossible for energy companies
to work and prices went up and biden's
radical agenda left america and our
allies vulnerable but there is some good
news despite everything that he did to
stymie oil and gas production his
administration can still take steps to
increase production lower the cost of
the pump lower the cost of every item we
buy at every store we go to lower the
cost of heating and cooling our homes he
can restart the keystone xl pipeline and
in spite of the lies that he and jensaki
have been
selling and telling according to the
premier of alberta canada this pipeline
could be turned around in less than one
year
once completed it would increase crude
oil capacity in the united states by
almost 900 000 barrels a day which would
make up and then some all the oil that
joe has been importing from russia and
he wouldn't have to beg venezuela and
iran and this isn't the only pipeline in
play most people don't know that in
europe the biden administration is
opposing the eastern mediterranean
pipeline which would supply western
europe with natural gas from israel a
long discussion with dory gold on my
radio show today joe needs to
immediately support this he once did he
doesn't anymore because he's controlled
by the climate alarmist cult now if the
administration reverses course now and
gives the green light to all of these
projects much needed natural gas would
begin to flow into europe it is
desperately needed and we can wean our
allies off of russian oil and energy and
stop making putin rich again and that
would bankrupt russia and putin's reign
of terror because russia would be poor
again now this new supply would
obviously be a factor in the global
energy market and of course the biden
administration could also reinstate
drilling in anwar and lift the ban on
new domestic and offshore exploration
here all of this would lower costs it
would increase supply supply and demand
crisscross and equal the price increase
of supply demand remains constant price
goes down and would also create
high-paying american jobs and we
wouldn't have to worry about russia we
wouldn't have to worry about the straits
of hormuz or any energy issues involved
in the middle east we would be energy
self-sufficient in other words energy
independent anyway that would require a
little courage from joey he would need
to stand up to his new green deal
climate alarmists in his own party but
he's clearly not willing to do that joe
would rather is now to beg the dictators
and the despots to produce more oil and
why he would ever negotiate with the
muellers of iran
that have threatened to wipe israel and
the u.s off the map to chant death to
america death to israel
iran that is the number one state
sponsor of terrorism worldwide and this
is where it gets really crazy
russia right now vienna is brokering the
new nuclear deal that joey wants with
iran and the united states iran won't
talk to us directly so russia's in the
middle negotiating i'm sure they're
doing a great job for iran and according
to just the news.com that's john
solomon's site a top russian negotiator
brag quote
iran got much more than they ever
expected we're talking about some 90
billion dollars in unfrozen cash and
other
assets
oil export guarantees very little
oversight surrounding iran's uranium
enrichment program also that joe biden
doesn't stand up to the climate
alarmists in his own party so what's
happening here joe biden is literally
putting his party's radical agenda over
your wallets he's willing to give you a
40-year high with inflation he's putting
his radical agenda over the safety and
security of the american people and
frankly the safety and security of
people around the world he's going to
make the number one state sponsor of
terror rich again
and none of that makes the world a safer
place sending money to a socialist
dictator like maduro and venezuela
sending an emissary over the caracas
over the weekend that doesn't make the
world a safer place giving opec all the
leverage they want over the u.s that
doesn't make the world a safer place and
make no mistake restricting oil and gas
production here in the u.s well that
will continue to spur
massive inflation obviously joe doesn't
care he'd rather deal with the dictators
than stand up to the radicals in his own
party
everything you buy
is produced and shipped and guess what
they use oil gas diesel to get it there
that's why month-over-month inflation
right here in the u.s continues to rise
unless of course you're living in this
alternate universe like circle back
propagandist gensake take a look
what specifically can you point to that
has worked to bring down inflation well
there are a number of steps we've taken
if you've seen if you compare month to
month we've seen inflationary pressure
or inflationary numbers go down month to
month even as we looked at the
year-to-year numbers go up which we
entirely predicted
now that is absolutely not true just
another gensake joe biden lie we are at
a 40-year high for inflation and that's
month after month but it wasn't sake's
only lie of the day jen still wants you
to believe that gas prices are only
going up because of vladimir putin and
greedy oil companies that are not taking
advantage of the leases that they have
generously given them take a look why
did you guys decide to re-brand the rise
and gas prices as the
hashtag putin price hike
i mean if you want to use that on fox i
welcome that does president biden think
that each of these 9 000 leases that are
available have oil or gas in them
because industry experts are saying that
that accusation is is a complete red
herring some permits are viable and some
are not
when you say that
this represents a fundamental
misunderstanding as to how this process
works
well first of all the nearly 60 percent
of leased acres remain non-producing
that's a lot uh in the range of 20
million acres so there are nine thousand
uh unused approved permits to drill in
they should not require that should not
require us inviting them to do that they
should do that themselves the additional
permits so would the president what
additional permits do they need there's
no they have the leases are there the
permits are there i don't think they
need an embroidered invitation to drill
that is their oil companies
i guess jinsocki probably gets 100 of
her information from msdnc and fake news
cnn and her cognitively struggling boss
that doesn't know what day it is but in
case you're watching tonight jen here's
an important fact you need to know and
you probably do despite your claim oil
and gas companies are not just sitting
on 9 000 unused approved oil drilling
permits these leases are issued prior to
exploration
so not all of those leases actually have
oil and gas in the ground that can be
extracted in other words energy
companies are not going to drill for oil
on a piece of land that ends up not
having oil even if they have the permit
to do so you might want to factor that
in does any of that make sense hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else